hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Brianna
white Brianna white I have here today
she's from the gaming channel sibling
rivalry she's checking it no [ __ ] we're
gonna check out a movie trailer why
bring a gamer for a movie trailer
because I can tell this stuff is video
game inspired do you know anything about
the movie hardcore Henry no I know
originally tidal hardcore they put
together like a short film and they got
a Kickstarter going short film [ __ ] is I
call it a trailer brilliant okay it's
brilliant it's an action film all done
through GoPro okay yeah so it feels like
a video game
it's really cool it's really cool I'm
interested to see how it goes yeah the
ten minutes are so spending and they
totally exceeded their amount that they
were aiming for so what we're watching
is the trailer for the future yeah I was
personally sent this from the digital
publicist at X STX entertainment what
did she know like I I got another
approval of before showing this hope we
get a red band trailer to because it's
[ __ ] violent hello Henry you remember
how you got here
this next heartbreaker
squeeze
you and I were miss tell our husband a
wife don't everyone
Henry they want your technology how
would you like to you yes
my back Henry they saw what are here to
help you
is your speech module install also
police we know you're not deaf
okay what a good news is that you're
gonna live a while the bad news is
there's an army standing between you and
your wife so let's go
Wow I'm diggin this way more than you
man it is acceptable you later
that's him Ross won't like bloody me now
are you gonna stand up and go spill this
nice nice
stop
Jesus I feel like the production value
of that is through the roof I know yeah
I think it's less than a million dollars
it comes to put together a god it looks
so [ __ ] looks very classy unique so
unique totally I'm a big fan of the
action genre like if there's one genre I
really grew up on it was action and what
I love from just seeing this footage is
the level of realism behind the action
in terms of there's some ridiculous
stuff you know like that one shot where
he starts going through the through the
man yeah I mean that was a cool moment
it's kind of unrealistic look the way
they capture it I'm like maybe it's the
element of the growth GoPro yeah that
makes it feel like you're it's really
happening
yeah I think that's so smart cuz I never
really thought of a GoPro is like that
yeah it's almost like it's trying to
promote a virtual reality sort of field
because it also has that like bubble
Miss feeling to it you can almost like
feel the peripherals or on your own fur
exactly no I think that's so interesting
exactly exactly unexplored mostly right
yeah yeah definitely I don't know who
the chick is who plays his wife she's
pretty cute he's got a great scream
present yeah she's cute totally that I I
like I'm living vicariously through this
Henry character and I hope they have a
sex scene with her
well they kind of implied that they do
they should have a sex scene with her so
I can live vicariously through Henry and
the theaters along with everyone else
that way we all feel like we're having
sex with her at the same time I hope
you're watching this this could easily
be like it's not a brand new plot you
know you know like okay guys I'm
assuming gets in an accident so they
kind of make him superhuman Eyeborg yeah
and then you know like his wife gets
kidnapped has to save her but what's
making this really unique of course is
the execution of it all the execution of
it absolutely there it there does feel a
certain kind of experience that I feel
like movies have tried to capture in
moments in their film like a complaint
all here like like there was the doom
movie where they did do first-person
point of view and then people were like
I'd rather just play the game instead of
watching that I don't get a feeling here
we're like I'd rather just play a game
I'm watching this like I want to
experience this in the theaters this
looks like it's gonna be an awesome
experience with some cool action scenes
it looks like there's some great stunt
work in here
I mean amazing like how else he fell in
a car yeah member that moment are you
like totally falls on the car and the
GoPros falling - yeah yeah would there
be shots really like kick someone every
fall on the other building like the
parkour and the stunt work the Falls the
kicks - people are taking it looks raw
and real I imagine that must have been
so hard with the GoPro you know because
you I mean I don't know how they filmed
it but I did they have a cinematographer
makini really likes just stuck to some
guys about face you know cuz I'm looking
at looking through skimming through this
trailer and I'm like the cinematography
looks pretty consistent it does Oh
she'll toko plea he is a badass actor I
love him and all those Neill Blomkamp
films I even liked him when he played
chappie so sharlto copley he's a great
actor and it's cool to see him in
another like action driven role but he
looks like he's having a blast with it
like I feel like everyone on this set
had a lot of fun oh yeah it looks like
it would be a fun ass movie - I also
feel like it doesn't take itself too
seriously which i think is which it
needs to be so important in any film
yeah in this time like it cannot take
itself too seriously or everyone's like
lame that's a great point because this
film easily could have taken itself too
seriously yeah but the fact that they're
making it like kind of a kinetic fun
experience makes it look that much more
appealing yes my one concern I'm gonna
be honest is that I hope it doesn't get
annoying you know yeah like it's too
much like motion sick yeah Cloverfield
yeah yeah exactly cuz yeah it's pretty
sporadic so I'm hoping that like I can
keep up with everything that's going on
like the action scenes and I hope it
doesn't get annoying there's gonna be
plenty of scenes in it words like yeah I
was worth watching the big screen anyway
guys thanks for tuning in to the channel
if you're new to it you can subscribe
today become a reject
Brianna White has a gaming channel plays
games and such and such and this on the
in touch and yeah don't don't make a
joke sounds like another word okay uh
Brianna why
subscriber channel and um thank you it
was a great pitch you know hardcore
Henry that's what they call little Ryan
my penis Breanna I got it the penis'
when you were training hardcore Henry
hardcore rye and right
hardcore right hardcore Ryan hardcore
hardcore Henry okay
hardcore Harry Henry Oh want to reveal
that